[Musik]
das podcast ist brought you the munich
es eben auch auf den ausgeteilten zettel
steht unser verlangen nach freiheit dass
ich 2006 publiziert habe und dass eben
eine position bezieht die in der
weltweiten debatte über die freiheit
höchst selten vertreten und eingenommen
wird obwohl sie nach meiner überzeugung
und nach der überzeugung einiger weniger
andere die in dem zusammenhang
vernünftigste genannt werden kann und
das ist die auffassung dass die selbst
zuschreibung von freiheit in den
geforderten stärksten sinne für uns
menschen das beste und eigentlich einzig
wahre ist was wir tun können und sich
nach allen regeln der kunst gegen alle
möglichen einwände behaupten kann und
dass ich deswegen mit also nicht als
solchen entschiedenheit wenn wir darauf
verzichten und selbst freiheit im
prägnanten vollen sinne zuzuerkennen wir
eben die gestaltungsmöglichkeiten sowohl
politischer wie persönlicher arzt dieses
lebenspraktisch aus der hand geben
das kann geradezu ein motiv seien dafür
philosophisch etwas anderes zu denken
als das was ich in diesem buch zu
verteidigen versuchen weil es ist eine
form der bequemlichkeit sich selbst bei
dem was man tut und wofür man kämpft
oder nicht kämpft eben nicht frei sowohl
getrieben
man irgendetwas veranlasst von irgendwem
und gezwungen mehr oder weniger zu
verstehen
deswegen der titel dieses buches unser
verlangen nach freiheit es eben ganz
wesentlich für diese angelegenheit
selbst das heißt wenn wir dieses
verlangen preisgeben und preisgeben
darauf zu insistieren dass wir dieses
prädikat uns mit recht zu schreiben dann
erlahmen wir eben auch inhalt den
belangen für die die freiheit schon
immer wichtig gewesen ist und wichtig
bleibt und sie wissen ja dass in der
heutigen debatte eben insbesondere auch
die neurowissenschaften die hirn
wissenschaften ein wesentliches wort
mitsprechen darüber was man für wahr
halten kann
über uns menschen und unsere einbettung
in den zusammenhang der dinge die wir
sonst kennen sondern auch gerne natur
nennt
und dass hier in viel skepsis viel
kritik unterwegs ist gerade von seiten
der neurowissenschaften und eigentlich
eine art denkt tendenz immer mehr
zunimmt dass wir zu unrecht uns in
früheren zeiten dieses prädikat der
freiheit zu billigen konnten aber nach
den erkenntnissen der
neurowissenschaften sowie sie sich immer
weiter erhalten und sicherlich auch
nicht in ihren seriösen ergebnissen zu
bezweifeln sind davon abstand nehmen
müssen diesen verlangen zu frönen dem
verlangen nach freiheit
darum scheint mir das also eine
insgesamt sehr wichtige
auseinandersetzung zu sein die wir hier
führen und eines der philosophische
lohnendsten themen
das sich denken lässt wie schon
angedeutet dass gewissermaßen label das
sich der position die ich vertreten
werde gegeben habe nichtwissen damals
dass dieses label schon von einer
anderen autorinnen
ebenfalls in vorschlag gebracht wurde
ist der sogenannte liebert arische
kompatibel ist muss um kurze sagen was
zuhause zu verstehen ist kompatibel ist
muss nennt man in der debatte eine
position die behauptet dass die
zuschreibung von freiheit die
zuerkennung von freiheit verträglich ist
mit der möglichkeit eines determinismus
des wirklichen insgesamt dass man also
nicht den determinismus ausschließen
muss um sich selbst und allen anderen
gleichartigen wesen freiheit
zuzuerkennen
das ist der kompatibel ist muss nun
meistens wird diese position die
eigentlich sehr viele anhänger hat in
der heutigen debatte mit einer
verminderung des freiheits anspruches
verbunden nachdem nach der so etwas wie
eine natürliche autonomie eine
natürliche autonomie eigentlich das ist
was wir mit freiheit meinen die gegeben
sein kann auch unter deterministischen
vorzeichen
diese art des standard kompatibel ist
muss vertrete ich indessen nicht und
deshalb flüge ich das wort liebert
arisch hinzu weil liebert arisch ist das
eingeführte wortes eingeführte
bezeichnung sword für freiheit im
starken sinne und dieser starke sinn
besteht insbesondere darin
dass wir bei freien entscheidungen die
wir treffen in der gegenwart dieser
entscheidung die wir treffen anders
entscheiden könnten
dass das also war sei dass wir anders
in der gegenwart in der wir eine
entscheidung fällen das nennt man eben
den liebert arisch also sehr stark sehr
ausgeprägt sehr pointiert verstandenen
begriff von willensfreiheit der
insbesondere in konflikt zu geraten
scheint mit der möglichkeit dass es
definitiv bestimmt ist wie alles ausgeht
und sich entwickelt wie der lauf der
dinge ist eben der deterministischen
thesen so dass also der standard
kompatibel ismus gewissermaßen die
freiheit absenkt um kompatibel mit der
möglichkeit eines determinismus der
wirklichkeit zu sein
während die position die ich vertrete
sich weigert der freiheit hier eine
minderung zuzumuten um mit der
möglichkeit des determinismus der
wirklichkeit in einklang zu sein sondern
behauptet das sei im falle möglicher
sozusagen frontal kein widerspruch
zwischen freiheit im stärksten sinne und
den determinismus und dieses leben ist
also liebert arischer kompatibel ist
muss den ich in diesem buch umfassend
verteidigt habe und es ist interessant
dass schon damals eine kollegin ein
amerikanische kollegin wohl unterwegs
war mit dem namen katri berlin steht er
auch auf ihrem zettel
katri berlin die ich glaube
dort lehrt und inzwischen eben ein
ausgedehntes buch der analytischen
schule geschrieben hat das eben typisch
angelsächsischen philosophie stils ganz
anders als ich als ich das in meinem
buch tour wo ich eher sagen wir mal
einen vernünftigen gedanken faden
argumentativ entwickler und verteidige
gegen denkbare einwände
dieses buch also in analytische stil mit
dem titel kurses laws and view will und
der titel weit die thermen ist da sind
meter und eigentlich fast in allen
fragen die in diesem buch berührt werden
in einklang ist mit diesem typisch
europäischen produkt des nachdenkens da
ist nicht vorgelegt habe das finde ich
eine ganz interessante sache und sendet
auch so etwas wie einen gewissen
vorgreifen trost aus an die die glauben
man könne sich eigentlich nur dann auch
philosophisches denken noch irgendwie
verlassen oder stützt oder beziehen wenn
es in der gegenwärtigen denkt hart und
streitpartner art vorgelegt wird wie es
eben die analytische philosophie vorgibt
das haben wir also jetzt hier
insofern
würde ich sagen denen sie ruhig ihr
beide bücher gründlich und sehen wie
eben auch die verschiedenen flüssen
viele so verschieden sie sind doch
durchaus zugangs gleichen ergebnissen
als vernünftig rational verteidigt bei
gelangen können
dann hatte ich auch auf der liste bei
den kleinen querschnitt durch die jetzt
vor allem hier in deutschland von
einigen jahren geführte debatte die
durch die zeitung ging über
hirnforschung und willensfreiheit und
wenn sie wissen wollen was man da so
alles diskutiert und was für art eben
von skepsis auf seite neben der
hirnforschung gegenüber so was wie
willensfreiheit geäußert wird dann
können sie sehr gut in diesem band die
beiträge die damals in der faz
erschienen sind und eben eigentlich den
ganzen ja wie soll ich sagen globus nach
hält dieses sektors debatte einschließen
können sie sich da sehr gut orientieren
also auch ein dass ein buch was ich
ihnen einmal gezeigt haben wollte gut
dass man aber nur bemerkungen
und ich wollte jetzt eben zu meinen
ersten überlegungen fortgehen die sowas
wie brille minar ian sind die aber eben
doch auch das phänomen in dem wir hier
rational nach steigen wollen also das
phänomen freiheit zunächst mal an den
ort rücken sollen an dem es sich
befindet meine auffassungen nach also
gewissermaßen nicht sofort nach
irgendetwas zu behaupten sondern
zunächst einmal dieses phänomen in
seinen eigenen spezifischen umkreis
zurück und da ist das erste was einem
auffällt dass fast die gesamte
philosophische diskussion und literatur
über die freiheit des menschen und dies
seit jahrhunderten krankt an einer
merkwürdigen und bei näherer betrachtung
durchaus folgenreichen verschieben des
worts ins von freiheit frei sein und
natürlich auch selbstverständlich in den
anderen sprachen liberté freedom und so
weiter und so fort
eine verschiebung des wortes ins von
einem wort für einen zustand oder eine
gesamtsituation des menschen zu einem
wort für bestimmte tätigkeiten bestimmte
aktionen als menschen wie etwa der
aktivität des wollens und handelns also
eine verschiebung von einem zustand wort
zu einem aktions wort wir sprechen
philosophisch bevorzugt von
handlungsfreiheit und willensfreiheit
und fokussieren dies so als gehe es bei
der freiheit um eine bestimmte art der
auslöser
von handlungen bzw willens akten oder
auch um eine vollzugs 8
eine art des vollziehen ist eine
handlung beziehungsweise eines willens
aktes oder denkt aktes freie auslösung
und freie vollzugs acht dreier vollzug
von handel und wollen im unterschied zu
nicht freier auslösung nicht freien
vollzug von handeln und wollen hier
erscheint das freie menschliche handeln
und wollen wie eine besondere art von
einzelereignis oder charakteristik von
einzel ereignis das in dieser art
manchmal auftritt und manchmal nicht und
die freiheit als waise der auslösung
oder freisetzung wie man dann auch sagt
oder vollziehung solcher
einzelereignisse erscheint als eine
besondere form der kausalität von
ereignissen oder ereignisreich der
kausalität der verursachung von
ereignissen oder ereignisreich
so erscheint also die freisetzung die
freiheiten der verschiebung des wortes
ins als eine besondere form der
kausalität
symptomatisch dafür ist die definition
der transzendentalen freiheit ja ganz
berühmt und prominent in der kritik der
reinen vernunft sie sein zitat ein
vermögen eine reihe von begebenheiten
von selbst anzufangen so dass in ihr
selbst nichts anfängt sondern sie als
unbedingte bedingung
jeder willkürlichen handlung über sich
keine derzeit nach vorhergehende
bedingung verschattet indessen doch ihre
wirkung
hier kommt nur qualität in der reihe der
erscheinungen anfängt aber darin niemals
einen schlechten ersten anfang ausmachen
kann
[Applaus]
die freiheit ist danach die selbst nicht
anfangen die ursache eines anfangs von
begebenheiten freiheit ist der erste
beginn einer reihe von ereignissen der
diese reihe verursacht oder anstößt
die verschiebung des wortes von einem
zustand wort zu einem aktions wort geht
also einher mit einer umdeutung des
sinnes von einer lagebeschreibung wie zb
ähnliche lage beschreibungen sind
reichtum oder armut ruhe oder hektik
gerechtigkeit oder ungerechtigkeit
konjunktur oder konjunkturschwäche das
sind also auch solche lage
beschreibungen wie das wort freiheit
eigentlich bezeichnet aber eben eine
verschiedene von der freiheit als eine
lagebeschreibung zu einem kausalität
modus der sich also auf einzelereignisse
anwenden lässt auf die sich eine
lagebeschreibung wir gar nicht anwenden
lässt
da sind dann viel mehr unterschiede wie
primär sekundär ursprünglich abgeleitet
zufällig notwendig zwangsläufig
ungesetzlich gesetzmäßig und so weiter
die prädikate die ein solches wort ein
solches wort für einen kausalität modus
eben noch weiter qualifizieren
diese verschiebung notieren wir also in
der philosophischen diskussion über das
freiheits phänomen die seit
jahrhunderten geführt wird und auch
gerade heute besonders in
die aber dem wortgebrauch in seiner
natürlichen und viel älteren vorgabe
eigentlich nicht das nicht gerecht wird
in unseren gewöhnlichen ausdrucksformen
hat sich indessen der sinn der freiheit
als wort für einen herrschenden oder
vermissten zustand eine lagebeschreibung
durchaus erhalten
wir sprechen von einem leben in freiheit
oder innen unfreiheit wir sprechen von
freiheitsberaubung
wir sprechen von bewegungsfreiheit von
der freilassung einer geisel eines
gefangenen eines sklaven
wir sprechen von politischer freiheit
oder unfreiheit von der pressefreiheit
der gedankenfreiheit oder denkt freiheit
der informationsfreiheit der
religionsfreiheit von freiheit oder
unfreiheit bei der erziehung eines
kindes von dem geist der freiheit oder
unfreiheit
also was sie auch eigentlich nehmen in
natürlicher rede immer haben sie
lagebeschreibung und eigentlich nie
kausalität modi und trotzdem hat sich
die philosophische diskussion dieser
angelegenheit so merkwürdig fest gehakt
das ist nicht ohne folgen ich werde
ihnen gleich erklären welche folgen
unter anderem damit einhergehen
spezifisch für den originalen sinn der
freiheit als situationsbeschreibung ist
insbesondere der gegensatz zur
unfreiheit
das ist ganz spezifisch in all diesen
gebrauchs weisen die ich beispielhaft an
führt habe freiheit steht im gegensatz
zur unfreiheit das was wir philosophisch
als willensfreiheit oder
handlungsfreiheit das heißt als
qualitäts modus auslöse modus immer zu
diskutieren steht gar nicht mehr
die im gegensatz zur unfreiheit dass
eine gravierende veränderung des
gesichts punktes das müsste uns
eigentlich sehr verdächtig vorkommen wie
will man beispielsweise das wort unfrei
oder unfreiheit auf die kantige
definition der positiven freiheit
anwenden wie will man das machen
das unvermögen eine reihe von
begebenheiten von selbst anzufangen ist
ja nicht das unfreie vermögen eine un-
oder eine unfreie reihe von
begebenheiten sondern es ist gar kein
vermögen dazu
es mag also eine reihe von begebenheiten
vorliegen aber sie fängt eben nicht von
selbst an sondern ist schon im gange
oder irgendwas aber das hat mit
unfreiheit ja nix zu tun
es liegt also keine freiheit vor
wenn man das versucht zu vereinen
aber es liegt auch keine unfreiheit im
spezifischen sinne des wortes vor
das heißt diese art von freiheit zu
reden steht quer wie eine gräte im hals
zu der zu den gegensatz von freiheit im
alten und immer mitgeführten gegensatz
der freiheit als eine lagebeschreibung
und das ist die unfreiheit
der freiheit wie wir sie philosophisch
kennen als eine besondere weise der
auslösung oder kausalität von handlungen
und willens akten ist also ihr
spezifischer gegensatz abhanden gekommen
die freiheit steht dadurch nicht im
gegensatz zu vorher sondern im gegensatz
zu ihrer platten verneinung der nicht
freiheit das ist der einzige noch
vorkommende gegensatz der freiheit in
der philosophischen debatte wir sprechen
wenn wir die freiheit des wollens oder
handelns verneinen nicht vom unfreien
wollen oder unfreien handeln sollen ganz
einfach vom licht freien
der mensch hat keinen freien willen
sagen wir dann der mensch handelt mich
frei basta das nicht freie steht dann
nicht in einem inneren verhältnis zur
freiheit sowie die unfreiheit jederzeit
in einem inneren verhältnis zur freiheit
steht dieses innere verhältnis zur
freiheit ist uns in der philosophischen
debatte über die menschliche freiheit
also weitgehend aus der sicht gerückt
sein merkwürdiges firmen wie gesagt ein
verlangen nach freiheit
was ich in dem buch titel ja
akzentuieren
das findet ja überhaupt immer nur stadt
vor dem hintergrund eines ausgangs oder
versuchs der befreiung aus unfreiheit
also einer tendenz einer inneren tendenz
die das verhältnis eben zur freiheit
intensiviert aber dieses wie gesagt ist
aus der thematisch geführten debatte
verschwunden
durch diese verschiebung des wortes ins
die wir unter anderem natürlich aber
insbesondere bei kant finden können
freiheit als qualität dieses
das würde ich nicht sagen sollen die
phänomenologie ist eher eine
philosophische bestrebung und methode
die versucht in diese selber mal
originalen noch sachverhalte
zurückzuführen
es kommt natürlich genau
ja also da würde ich jetzt gar nicht
sagen dass das gerade die phänologie ist
wobei die phänomenologie so viel also
sie haben auch genannt das ist natürlich
schon ein ein von den klassischen
technologien relativ weit entfernt hat
denker aber soll wenn man die mal als
eine der chor seine medaillen ansetzt
er hat so viel über das freiheits
phänomen wenn ich recht orientiert bin
gar nicht nachgedacht
also da würde ich der phänomenologie
jedenfalls keine meiner kenntnis keine
verschärfende tendenz zu messen sondern
die
architekten dieser verschiebung sind
andere was insbesondere dieses sich
festklammern sich festmachen an der
kausalität der freiheit fall dass eine
form der qualität das ist kann noch
unbekannt ist ein wahrer gigant nicht
nur in der philosophie sondern in
unserem gesamten denken du das was ganz
philosophisch durchgeboxt hat das prägt
uns bis in die alt bis in das
alltägliche bewusstsein in einen zwar
weltweit
also dieses innere verhältnis zur
freiheit im verhältnis ebenso umfeld ist
uns aus der sicht gerückt worden durch
die beschriebene verschiebung der
unfreie findet sich niemals ab mit
seiner unfreiheit der nicht frei fühlt
sich höchstens mundtot gemacht mit bezug
auf die freiheit so etwas ganz anderes
der dem unfreiheit attestiert wird der
wird jederzeit kämpfen dazu da darum
frei zu werden einen ausgang zu finden
aus der unfreiheit der dem ich erkläre
pech gehabt du bist nicht frei dem ist
der mund gestopft und das ist die
situation der diskussion in der wir uns
befinden ist also interessant ich
beschreibe in das wohn und weise darauf
hin was damit einhergeht
also es geht damit einher als erstes das
verschwinden der unfreiheit aus der
gesamten debatte manchen euro
philosophen oder neurowissenschaftler
meinen es könne nicht sein dass wir frei
sind irgendwelche verschaltungen so das
wort von wolf singer in unseren gehirnen
dahin führen dass wir etwas wollen oder
etwas tun das ist das kernargument
wenn verschaltungen in unseren gehirnen
dahin führen dass wir etwas wollen dann
könne es nicht sein dass wir frei sind
das heißt sie reden uns ein dass
freiheit wenn irgendwo dann in dem aus
lösungs modus unseres verhaltens und
denkens wohne
jedoch ist der auslöser modus immer an
das feuer von neuronen gekoppelt deren
feuern wiederum ein anderes feuern und
so weiter soll daraus etwa folgen dass
wir nicht frei sind ja gar nicht frei
sein können dass es absurd
ein riesen irrtum hervorgerufen durch
jede verschiebung des wortsinn denen
sich die philosophie selbst hat zu
schulden kommen lassen
spielen wir noch ein wenig mit dem
falschen gedanken die freiheit sei eine
vollzugs oder ein aus lösungs modus von
einzelaktionen des menschenbildes akte
oder handlungen kanal schallt
mechanismus ein schaltelemente einschalt
schritt man kann einer bestimmten
gegebenen aktion welche sie auch sei
nicht ansehen ob sie eine freie oder
nicht frei ist auch der auslösung einer
handlung oder aktion kann man den
unterschied des freien vom nicht freien
oder das freien verbund freien gar nicht
anmerken
denn vor oder ohne auslösung ist gar
nichts da aber mit oder in der auslösung
ist eben irgendein impuls irgendeine
initiative irgendeine vorlage irgendeine
aktion schon da das auslösen einer
aktion ist selbst wieder eine aktion
und wenn man der bestimmten aktion den
unterschied von freiheit und nicht
freiheit gar nicht anmerken kann dann
auch nicht der bestimmten auslösung
einer
aktion das bedeutet unser bild der
freiheit in weiten teilen ihrer
philosophischen diskussion ist so dass
freiheit auch von nicht freiheit nicht
mehr durch bestimmte kriterien oder
manifest werdende charaktere zu
unterscheiden ist
das ist also höchst merkwürdig durch
diese verschiebung ist es nicht nur so
dass die unfreiheit als gegen halt des
freiheits strebens verschwunden ist
sondern auch sogar der vorgeschlagene
gegensatz der platten verneinung denn
nicht verhallt kann sich gar nicht mehr
ausweisen
durch bestimmte kriterien in der
beschreibung von handlungen sondern wenn
es um die auslösung und den aus lösungs
modus von handlungen geht da wo keine
handlung ist haben wir halt keinen und
da wo irgendeine vorliegt können wir
nicht sagen ist jetzt weil der nicht
ausgelöst die ist halt erstmal da also
das gesamte gebiet der verneinung dessen
worum es uns zu tun ist ist aus der
sicht gekommen
durch diese verschiebung von einer
lagebeschreibung zu einem aus lösungs
modus von handlung das ist doch höchst
interessant und höchst verdächtig weil
alles doch durch seine verneinung die
signifikanz bekommt dieses die etwas hat
erst wenn man den unterschied kennt
zwischen dem was man möchte und dem was
das gegenteil davon wäre oder das nicht
sein davon wäre erst dadurch bekommt
etwas seinen seine schärfe seine
klarheit seine bestimmte
können wir zu anfang dieser vorlesung
denn schon irgend etwas darüber sagen
was die freiheit denn wäre oder sein
soll wenn sie nicht eine form der
kausalität von handlungen nicht eine
aktions oder aus lösungs weise sondern
ein zustand eine verfassung eine
lebenssituation des menschen ist es gibt
den main sagte nss sehr schönen und
treffenden ausdruck im deutschen das
gefasst science auf aktionen oder
vorkommnisse jemand ist gefasst
auf vorkommnisse auf aktion auf etwas
was ich begegnet ich bin auf etwas
gefasst
oder ich war nicht darauf gefasst was
ist eine fassung
oder was ist gefasst sein wir sprechen
davon dass eine quelle zb gefasst oder
eingefasst ist
erst wenn eine quelle gefasst ist oder
eingefasst dann kann man aus ihr
schöpfen
abseits der erfassung einer quelle ist
sie wie man sagen könnte ein
einzugsbereich von wasser oder von
feuchtigkeit rinnsalen etc
ich denke dass die freiheit in einer
solchen fassung oder wie man auch sagen
kann engführung zwischen einem
einzugsbereich des menschlichen handelns
und wollens und dem gefassten handeln
und wollen eines menschen liegt hier ist
der unterschied von freiheit und
unfreiheit von freiheit und nicht
freiheit mit händen zu greifen
das unfreie handeln oder wollen eines
menschen hat nicht nur nicht in ihm
nicht in seiner eigenen fassung liegende
rinnsale und strenge der
handlungsanleitung dass viel mehr hat
jede menschliche aktion notwendigerweise
jede menschliche aktion hat nicht der
fassung dieses menschen liegende
anbahnungen und rinnsale aus denen es
sich eben in dieser fassung speist
sondern die will ich sagen konstruktions
arts der fassung oder die anstalt die
installation der art von fassung
jena rinnsale die zusammenlaufen in der
gefassten quelle also die konstruktions
hat der anstalten oder installation der
verengung und einfassung des
einzugsbereich von handlungen in das
gefasste wollen und handeln des
individuums diese ist dann frei der
betreffende mensch handelt etwa unter
zwang oder er handelt ihm durch oder er
steht unter einer obsession oder hypnose
er versteht in einer fast nahrung einer
vorenthaltung von information und so
weiter und so fort all die
beschreibungen von eben einer unfreien
installation oder unfrei installierten
fassung der handlungs anbahnenden
rinnsale die immer von woanders her
fließen in dem einzelnen menschen also
dieses gefasst sein auf die weise wie
gefasst sein auf handlung vorkommendes
so weiter
da wohnt die freiheit als ein eben
markanter unterschied zur unfreiheit
die freiheit ist also wenn sie gegeben
ist ebenso wie die unfreiheit eine
gewisse bleibende weil installierte
verfassung der engführung zwischen einem
ausgedehnten übrigens nicht nur
individuellen sondern über viele
individuen erstreckten einzugsbereich
menschlichen
und den aktionen denken wollen handeln
des einzelnen individuums also das wort
was mir am ehesten eine solche
lagebeschreibung abstrakt auszudrücken
scheint ist verfassung die freiheit ist
also eine verfassung und zwar eine
verfassung über den einzugsbereich
menschlichen handelns wie er sich eng
führt in ein gefasst sein
auf handeln und vorkommnisse des lebens
die freiheit ist eine verfassung etwa
vergleichbar wie die gesundheit nicht
eine art impulsgeber wie durch jene
verschiebung des boards sind suggeriert
wird eine verfassung ist keinen
impulsgeber kausal impuls einspeist
also gesundheit ist natürlich eine
verfassung des körpers oder man kann
auch sagen der psycho physischen
konstitution des individuums dass es die
freiheit nicht sondern nur vergleichbar
insofern mit der gesundheit sondern eine
verfassung der für jeden menschen und
für jeden frei agierenden überhaupt zu
bewerkstelligende neng führungen
zwischen dem einzugsbereich oder
netzwerk des handelns in dem jemand
situiert ist und eben den persönlichen
oder individuellen handeln und agieren
selbst diese merkwürdige fassungs
leistung
das findet statt in der freiheit oder
aber eben unfreiheit und dann auf
verschiedene weise die man spezifizieren
kann niemand wiederum beschreiben kann
wo ist dann die verschiedenheit zwischen
allen freien solchen fassung und
freiheitsrechten fassung
das macht mir auch immer so merkwürdig
dass die der tägliche umgang das
tägliche reden von freiheit sich da
etwas gehalten hat und eigentlich
selbstverständlich fortsetzt was in der
philosophischen debatte des problems
ganz sogar außer gucken gerückt wurde
ja ja das gibt es zweifellos das ist
eben etwas was man beachten muss das in
dem die unfreiheit in einem inneren
verhältnis zur freiheit steht eine
graduiert einsteiger vagheit ihn die
sache selbst eingeschrieben ist trotzdem
möchte ich beharren dass diese
steigerbar kite kombiniert ist mit einem
mit bestimmten schwellen mit bestimmten
stellen
das werde ich später noch erklären jetzt
einstweilen auf sich beruhen lassen bei
deren überschreitung freiheit im vollen
sinne gegeben ist
bei deren unterschreitung freiheit fehlt
das heißt die gradierbau zeit ist
kontaktiert gegen gewichtet mit einer
digitalen unterscheidung des frei
science vom nicht frei sein sonst
könnten wir nicht in bestimmten fällen
eben mit recht etwa jemanden davon los
sprechen
in der begangenen tat frei gewesen zu
sein und das ist ganz wesentlich dass
eine solche lossprechung vernünftig ist
in manchen fällen und eben insofern auf
jeden fall zum begriff der freiheit dazu
kommen muss aber das muss man eben
denken können in verbindung mit diesen
graduiert barren gegensatz zur
unfreiheit
da haben sie jedenfalls ganz recht
danach zu fragen also noch mal nicht die
verfassung des körpers wie die
gesundheit sondern eine verfassung der
für jeden menschen und für jeden frei
agierenden zu bewerkstelligen den hang
führung zwischen dem einzugsbereich oder
netzwerk des handels in dem man situiert
ist und eben den persönlichen handeln
und agieren selbst dieses erwähnten
netzwerk aus dem sich das handeln speist
wie die quelle aus den rinnsalen
schließt sowohl körperliche und
seelische vermögen fähigkeiten des
einzelnen ein wie auch bestimmte
bedingungen in seiner umgebung wie etwa
evident im falle der bewegungsfreiheit
bewegungsfreiheit ist eine solche
zusammensetzung aus eben den
persönlichen bewegungs fähigkeiten und
bestimmten bedingungen in der umgebung
der mit bewegungsfreiheit herbst also an
diesem evidenten und sehr gewöhnlichen
beispiel für das was man freiheit nennt
sieht man schon dass eben beiderlei
verfassungs beiträge zur freiheit
gehören wie auch vor allem die
verhältnisse und beziehungen zu anderen
menschen
bei dieser entführung beteiligt sind
etwa dass jemand familienvater ist oder
angestellter oder ein demonstrant oder
schüler oder auch studenten denn keiner
handelt und will im leeren raum sondern
immer gibt es vor gebannte wege des
handelns und wollen es relativ auf die
freiheit oder unfreiheit etwa zur
abweichung oder zur weiterentwicklung
oder zur weigerung und so weiter
bestehen und sich definieren
nehmen sie nur so ein phänomen wie die
macht im politischen sinne macht ist
immer etwas das einem selbst gewisse
handlungen ermöglicht die jemand ohne
die macht nicht hätte aber die macht
wächst einem erst zu durch die
unterstützung anderer und klar ist dass
das wollen und handeln eines menschen
mit macht völlig anders aussieht als das
eines menschen ohne macht diese
machtverhältnisse gehören somit zum
einzugsbereich des wollens und handelns
eines bestimmten menschen
obwohl diese macht ihm zu wächst aus dem
verhältnis zu anderen und so im falle
der freiheit
obwohl die freiheit ihm zu wächst aus
dem verhältnis zu anderen ist sie doch
seine wie überhaupt natürlich die macht
ein eminentes phänomen der freiheit ist
sie gehört zentral zu der gemeinden
verfassung die die freiheit oder aber um
freiheit eines menschen ist er
ohnmächtig ist eben frei es ist ganz und
gar illusorisch zu glauben dass die
freiheit anstatt ihres mangels wo sie
der stadt findet eine art ein montiertes
schaltelemente in der aktions auslösung
des einzelnen individuums ist zwar ist
richtig wir noch genau untersuchen
werden dass etwa das was man
entscheidungen treffen nennt eine
kompetenz des individuums kraft seiner
freiheit ist aber das entscheiden und
zwar jegliches entscheiden
auch das eines allmächtigen gottes wenn
wir seine existenz annehmen muss
auf basis einer vorbereitung oder eines
vorbaus von installation möglicher
entscheidungs bahnen und wege sowie
triftige gründe und gegen gründe sowie
einsetzbarer macht vermögen und
ressourcen erfolg also dieses bild was
ich ihn entwerfe ist keineswegs so
gebaut dass man sagen kann hier lässt
sich die freiheit zwar auf das endliche
subjekt des menschen anwenden
aber da wir ja auch von einer möglichen
freiheit gottes etwa bei der schöpfung
der welt sprechen versagt dieser begriff
das tut er nicht
weil selbst in diesen fällen eines
eminenten gebrauchs ist das gleiche
phänomen zu finden dass eine solche
einführung eines vorbaus der freiheit in
die freie aktion fällig ist
das gehört also zu dem was in wiesen
entscheidung ist und daneben auch freie
entscheidung ist das hier in st vorbau
installiert wird oder ein vorbau in eine
installierte fassung eingeführt wird
das alles sind also netzwerke im
hintergrund freie entscheidung diese
macht vermögen ressourcen entscheidungs
bahnen und wege die eingeführt sind und
so weiter
das alles sind netzwerk im hintergrund
freie entscheidung die gerade den
freiheits charakter tragen wenn sie eben
ihn diesen charakter tragen die nicht
starre verbindung zwischen entscheidungs
vorbau oder entscheidungs ressourcen und
getroffene entscheidung ist ein
wesentliches element der freiheit
deshalb die wichtigkeit eben auch einer
lebendigen natur dessen den man freiheit
zu schweigen kann jetzt warten sie mal
jetzt jemand
das finde ich jetzt nicht
macht und verantwortung verpflichtung
und rechtfertigung der unterschied von
richtig und verfehlt recht und unrecht
usw alles dieses ohne welches man
eigentlich nie gedacht hat dass freiheit
stattfinden könnte sind die züge einer
gewissen verfassung über die ein subjekt
der freiheit aus dem einzugsbereich
seines handelns und den darin verwobenen
letzten und rinnsalen erst ein
bestimmtes wollen und handeln macht und
dass im falle der freiheit ganz anders
als im falle der unfreiheit und das ist
gar nicht einmal unähnlich zur
verfassung der gesundheit mit der ja die
freiheit als verfassungs wort verglichen
werden kann
gesundheit vermittelt dir ja der
einzelne physiologische prozesse aus dem
gefüge des körpers insgesamt gespeist
wird
wenn jemand krank ist dann fällt diese
speisung einzelner physiologischer
prozesse eben ganz anders aus entweder
hypertrophe oder schwach oder
unregelmäßig etc
ähnlich im falle der freiheits
verfassung oder aber um freiheits
verfassung eines menschen
ein vorzug dieser betrachtung sad der
freiheit als verfassungen oder zustand
situationsbeschreibung besteht darin
dass wir so im begriff der freiheit
nicht die verbindung verlieren zwischen
der freiheit als entscheidungs willens
und handlungskompetenz des einzelnen
individuums und freiheit als prägung der
sozialen und politischen verhältnisse in
denen viele menschen zusammen existieren
das erstere nenne ich individuelle
freiheit das zweite möchte ich als
kommune freiheit bezeichnet also bei
dieser betrachtung sad der freiheit als
eine verfassung verliert man nicht diese
verbindung in den sinn des freiheits
phänomens zwischen individueller
freiheit und kommune freiheit die
individuelle freiheit wiederum zerlegt
sich dann in handlungsfreiheit und
wildes freiheit die wir später
ausführlich behandeln werden wie ich
mich in dieser vorlesung natürlich
überhaupt auf die individuelle freiheit
konzentriere
ohne aber eben die kommune freiheit
dabei aus den augen zu verlieren ist
wirklich erstaunlich wie eben wiederum
durch die verschiebung des wortes ins
von einem wort für den gesamtzustand die
verfassung zu einem wort für den aus
lösungs modus von handlung praktisch
vollkommen das wort freiheit zu einer
evokation geworden
eine komplikation dass man sagt ja was
politische oder soziale freiheit ist hat
ja gar nichts zu tun mit dem was wir
hier so wichtig diskutieren die hill
freiheit beispielsweise das individuum
das ist ja was völlig anderes
also hat man eben zb dieses buch hier
dafür kritisiert da ist das bildchen
drauf von delacroix dass die freiheit
das volk führend heißen titel hat und
eben von de lacroix angesichts der gegen
restaurativen bestrebungen um 18 30 in
frankreich gegen die napoleonischen
erfahrungen und die französische
revolution gemalt wurde und eben
natürlich für politischen soziale
freiheit steht
wieso auf diesem buch ein bild dessen zu
finden sei was doch gar nichts zu tun
hat mit dem was darin diskutiert werde
das ist eben ein irrtum
diese beiden sachen hängen wie ich ihn
noch weiter erklären möchte die nicht
zusammen
es ist meines erachtens höchst
bedauerlich dass die philosophische
diskussion über begriff und möglichkeit
der willensfreiheit und der freiheit
überhaupt sich dahin entwickelt hatte
in diesen beiden sachen fast nur noch
eine ecke lokation des wortes freiheit
zu erblicken so als hätte die freiheit
der sozialen verhältnisse nichts zu tun
mit der freiheit des einzelnen menschen
und umgekehrt
aber das bildet eben einen engen
zusammenhang nur ist der zusammenhang
keineswegs keineswegs so zu verstehen
dass ein einzelner mensch nur dann
freiheit besitzt wenn er in einer
maximal freien gesellschaft leben das
nicht
das hängt auch zusammen mit den wo
nachgefragt wurde dass wir nicht nur
eine gravur wahrheit sondern eben auch
eine schwellenüberschreitung in dem wort
freiheit denken müssen das stimmt also
nicht in jeder gesellschaft in jeder
gesellschaft gibt es noch den
unterschied von persönlicher freiheit
und persönlicher und freiheit des
einzelnen
dennoch ist es eben meines erachtens
interessant dass in jedem fall die
freiheit oder unfreiheit des einzelnen
sich als eine verfassung der immer und
überall zu leistenden engführung
zwischen den sozialen netzwerken ihren
ressourcen normen gesetzen handlungs
bahnen und rollen geltenden gründen und
gegen gründen usw einerseits und eben
der individuellen willens und
handlungsmacht des einzelnen individuums
andererseits konstituiert der mensch
existiert nicht ohne eine solche
verfassung sei sie gut oder schlecht für
ihn vorteilhaft oder nachteilig schwach
oder stark wie seine gesundheit
existiert deshalb nicht ohne einen
status seiner freiheit einen status
seiner freiheit bzw einen status seiner
unfreiheit dieser status seiner freiheit
liegt nicht außerhalb seiner eigenen
gestaltung und einflussmöglichkeit wenn
er auch nicht unabhängig von anteilen
ist die nicht in der hand des einzelnen
ligen
der status der freiheit ist vielmehr
eine zusammenkunft eine konvergenz von
gestaltungsmöglichkeit des einzelnen und
dem was ihnen an was ihr an wilden
rinnsalen aus der situation in der er
etwa sozial existiert entgegen fliegen
sie ist nicht unabhängig von seinen
eigenen einfluss dieser status hier
drängt sich ein anderer vergleich auf
ein anderer vergleich mit der freiheit
ein vergleich der wohl noch wichtiger
ist als der bereits geführte mit der
gesundheit
hier drängt sich ein anderer vergleich
aus auf wo es sich ähnlich verhält und
das ist der vergleich mit der sprache
jeder mensch spricht jeder hat einen
status seiner sprache der nicht
außerhalb seiner eigenen gestaltung und
einflussmöglichkeit liegt wer wolle dass
es bezweifeln dennoch ist dieser status
zweifellos auch nicht unabhängig von
anteilen die nicht in der hand des
einzelnen ligen die freiheit ist also
wie die sprache vergleichbar gehen wir
diesen vergleich etwas nach obwohl nur
einzelne individuen sprechen können ist
der gemeinschaftliche besitzt der
sprache oder die kommune sprache unter
allen menschen ursprung und ständige
hintergrund bedingungen des sprechens
eines jeden
hinzu kommt die freiheit allein den
individuellen akteuren zu nur individuen
können frei sein in ihrem wollen und
handeln aber auch sie könnten nicht frei
agieren ohne den hintergrund der
kommunen freiheit als gemeinschaftlichen
besitz aller menschen aus dem die
freiheit des einzelnen prinzipiell erst
entspricht
die freiheit als gemeinschaftlicher
besitz ist so wenig
die summe der freiheit im wollen und
handeln einzelne wie die sprache als
gemeinschaftlicher besitz die summe
sprich akten einzelner ist also hier ein
vergleichs punkt vokabular bedeutung
kommunikations und formulierung regeln
möglicherweise bezug all dies und noch
mehr ist nichts was ein einzelner
sprecher von sich aus überhaupt
entwickeln kann wieder ein vokabular
noch bedeutung noch kommunikation zur
formulierung regeln noch möglichen
wahrheit' bezug den wir als einzelne
sprecher realisieren können wir als
einzelne überhaupt entwickeln jeder muss
es aus einem gemeinsamen fundus der
sprache also aus der kommunen sprache
lernen erwerben sich erst aneignen
ähnlich im falle der freiheit
norman gründe kartierung und bausteine
von verhalten und handlungen verfahren
der entscheidungsfindung die phänomen
und die phänomene und regeln von geltung
und ihrer beurteilung das alles und mehr
gehören zum fundus der freiheit als
gemein besitz also als kommune freiheit
die einzelne unmöglich anlegen können
einen solchen fundus jeder muss wiederum
daraus seine persönliche freiheit
beziehen lernen erwerben oder er kann
eben nicht frei wollen und handeln die
persönliche individuelle freiheit ist
also nur die spitze eines eisbergs der
im all ein sozial möglichen fundus der
freiheit schwimmt
das sprechen ist eine besondere
erfindung aller menschen oder der
menschlichen gemeinschaft dank derer der
einzelne erst zu sprechen vermag die
freiheit ist eine besondere erfindung
aller menschen oder der menschheit
insgesamt dank derer der einzelne erst
frei zu agieren vermag aber dass immer
wieder einsetzende sprechen einzelner
kommt zweifellos der entwicklung der
menschlichen sprache zu gute es gibt
also ein feedback oder ist immer wieder
einsetzende freier agieren einzelne
kommt der entwicklung der menschlichen
freiheit zu gute
auch hier gibt es ein solches feedback
wir sind von unserer gemeinsamen sprache
gewissermaßen geschickt oder abgeordnet
um zu sprechen
damit ein solches feedback stattfindet
und wir sind von unserer kommunen
freiheit geschickt oder abgeordnet um
frei zu erklären damit es auch da ein
feedback geben dann würden wir nicht
immer von neuem geschickt dann versiegte
die gemeinsame sprache allmählich und
versiegte eben auch die freiheit was wir
durch die sprache und sprechfähigkeit
einzelner können ist ungeheuerlich
ebenso ungeheuerlich ist was wir durch
die freiheit und das frei agieren
einzelner individuen können es herrscht
also ein eigentümliches geben und nehmen
zwischen der allen gemeinsamen sprache
als gewissermaßen sprachloser ressource
alles sprechens und den wirklichen
sprechen akten einzelner individuen
ähnlich zwischen der freiheit als einer
latent vorhandenen ressourcen besitz der
menschlichen gemeinschaft insgesamt und
den freiheits akten der einzelnen
individuen was nun hat was nun hat bei
der sprache ist es
uns allen klar was die sprache
davon hat dass sie dieses legat oder
diese abordnung zum sprechen einzelner
erteilt aber was hat die menschliche
gemeinschaft davon dass immer einzelne
individuen vor geschickt werden um
persönlich frei zu agieren
alle anderen populationen lebendige
wesen in der natur jedenfalls der
unseres globus kenne nichts
vergleichbares
bei ihnen gibt es höchstens das phänomen
der funktionen teilung oder
arbeitsteilung etwa bei den bienen
ameisen oder bestimmten herden und
schwärmen und so weiter ein ganzes von
fälligen lebensfunktionen wird dann so
organisiert dass von verschiedenen
gruppen und verschiedenen individuen
verschiedene spezialfunktionen zum
ganzen beigesteuert werden bei den
ameisen und bieten und so weiter ich
möchte diese art der kollektivierung
eine organismus koordination der
gemeinschaften nennen die sehr häufig
ist in der sonstigen natur und bei
anderen lebendigen populationen aber die
menschliche gemeinschaft ist kein
organismus kollektiv
es ist kein organismus kollektiv sie
wird vielleicht manchmal damit
verwechselt und gerade wenn uns das
verlangen nach freiheit abhanden kommt
dann wird sie damit verwechselt die
menschliche gemeinschaft ist kein
organismus kollektiv der einzelne ist
gerade dank der freiheits erfindung kein
wie immer geartetes werkzeug der
gemeinschaft insgesamt gerade dank der
freiheits erfindung ist er ist nicht
vielmehr handelt es sich um eine radikal
antagonistische koordination also nicht
eine organische sondern eine art
kommunistische koordination in der
sowohl der alt die einzelnen aus
freiheit sich gegeneinander
antagonistisch verhalten als auch jeder
gegen die von der gemeinschaft
entwickelten gemeinsamen normen und
erwartungen antagonistisch verstößt oder
dazu wenigstens ermächtigt ist
diese ermächtigung entschuldigung was
ist jetzt los
diese ermächtigung bedeutet aber
keineswegs erlaubnis nicht dass sie das
verwechselt ermächtigung bedeutet
keineswegs erlaubnis denn die in der
gemeinschaft als gültige achteten normen
gesetze richtlinien beanspruchen richtig
rechnen ist
richtig recht oder wahr zu sein so dass
ein verstoß gegen das richtige
jedenfalls verfehlt und daher unerlaubt
ist und oft sagt sanktionen unterliegt
aber er ist eben doch möglich oder
besser ermöglicht oder eben ermächtigt
durch den fundus der kommunen freiheit
das bedeutet also antagonistische
collect an antagonistische kollektiv die
menschliche gemeinschaft denn sie
besteht gerade auch darin dass der
einzelne dem sie zukommt die freiheit
seiner aktion aus eigener souveränität
und nicht als glied einer gemeinschaft
entscheidet diese souveränität besäße er
nicht ohne das legat legat heißt eben
vermächtnis des gemeinschaftlichen
fundus der freiheit wie auch die
fähigkeit alles zu sagen nicht ohne
seine sprache aus dem fundus der
sprachgemeinschaft geschöpft zu haben
also erschöpft die sprachfähigkeit aus
dem fundus und damit ist ja dazu
ermächtigt alles zu formulieren und dass
das viel einbringt im falle der sprache
ist klar
und das ist eben auch sehr viel
einbringt im falle der freiheit das
werden wir sehen
der entscheidende punkt des regals der
freiheit im einzelnen individuum ist
also die macht zur abweichung von dem
was in der gemeinschaft für gültig und
verbindlich erachtet wird
komme ich gleich darauf den paulus das
verhältnis von gemeinschaftlichen
freiheits und individueller freiheit ist
die ausrichtung von allgemein gültigkeit
und verbindlichkeit im fundus kein
einzelner mensch kann die gültigkeit von
regeln und normen errichten und
kompetenz zur abweichung von und gar dem
verstoß gegen gültige regeln im freien
einzelne individuen also das ist also
die freiheit eine erfindung weil sie die
gültigkeit aufrecht erhält bei
ermächtigung zum verstoß gegen sie die
gültigkeit wird nicht bestritten
durch diese ermächtigung zum verstoß
gäbe es nur nicht das legat zur
abweichung vom gültigen in der freiheit
des einzelnen
so würde der charakter des gültigen
richtigen und der verbindlichkeit von
normen im fundus der freiheit nicht nur
nicht weiterentwickelt sondern er würde
erodiert und zerstört das heißt gerade
durch die herausforderung die in der
abweichung vom gültigen vorgeführt wird
bleibt der entwicklungs druck und
rechtfertigung stop in bezug auf
gültigkeit in jeder art forciert wird er
sogar forcieren bleibt nicht nur
erhalten sondern wird forciert durch die
antagonistische abweichung kompetenz der
einzelnen akteure das heißt durch deren
starke liebert arische freiheitsliebe
tages habe ich ja schon erklärt werden
alle bereiche in denen das gültige von
ungültigen das richtige vom verfehlten
das norm entsprechende von norman
verstoß unterschieden wird
alle diese bereiche werden dadurch
gekräftigt und weiterentwickelt also
auch das was wir vor um erkundungen etwa
ende kunstform entdeckung form
entwicklung der technik und so weiter
canon auch das gehört und ist verbunden
mit dem phänomen freiheit weil hier
werden immer gültigkeit sind erneut auf
den prüfstand gerückt durch die freiheit
der einzelnen und nur unter einem
solchen druck
nun gibt es eine fortentwicklung von dem
als nötig erachteten
den fundus das ist sehr sehr wichtig wir
müssen uns klar machen dass die
errichtung und anerkennung von gültigen
normen und ihre verbindlichkeit steht
und fällt mit der kompetenz zum verstoß
und zur abweichung der ermächtigung zum
verstoß und zur abweichung und damit der
individuellen freiheit in jedem dem
geltungsbereich unter fallenden
individuum ihren impetus so heißt es bei
paulus im römerbrief ihren impetus
gewinnt die verfehlung durch das gebot
die verfehlung hamm attia ist die
abweichung und diese abweichung fliesst
gewissen maßen oder bekommt ihre
nachdrücklichkeit durch das errichtete
gebucht formen der nabu saha markierte
cent oder ein anderer satz in diesem
sinn aber die macht zum verstoß ist das
gesetz haben sie genau diese von mir
vorher erklärte spannung die errichtet
ist in der freiheit zwischen der
beanspruchten der errichtung von
gültigkeit im fundus in der kommunen
freiheits und dem legat oder der
ermächtigung zum verstoß wirklich noch
intensiver hätte dynamis tsh matthias
ottmann das können sie sozusagen im
gleichen in beiden richtungen lesen dass
ein wesentlicher freiheitsgedanke war
der paulus 17 studieren da haben sie
eine enorme original kraft in bezug auf
freiheit bisschen schwer zu entdecken
man muss eigentlich wissen wonach man
sucht
aber dann wird man sehr schnell fündig
also wenn sie es noch nicht getan haben
dann tun sie es mal
es gibt also einen zusammenhang zwischen
der errichtung von gültigkeit
maßstäblichkeit richtigkeit was kein
einzelner mensch kann
und der macht oder kraft oder kompetenz
sie zu berechnen und das ist dieses
freiheits verhältnis wo sie eigentlich
sein da ist in dieser antagonistischen
kollektivierung menschlicher individuen
die ganz anders ist als eine organische
oder funktionen arbeitsteilige
gesellschaft
das ist einfach nicht hinreichend bei es
bleibt dabei dass natürlich die
verfehlung eine verfehlung ist
ich möchte dass doch etwas genauer mit
ihnen erkunden bevor wir in die
einfach nur mal aufgezählt beispiele
normativer gültigkeit
das ist eine irre vielfalt auch ganz
unterschiedlich gebauter errichteter
gültigkeit mal wüst durcheinander
aufgeführt brauche ich gar nicht im
einzelnen hervorzuheben es ist sowohl in
den einzelnen wissenschaften oder
künsten haben wir die lecks artis an
dritter stelle die wahrheit'
orientierung wissenschaftlicher
erkenntnis enorm richtige enorm wichtige
angelegenheit fünf das religiöse
toleranz gebotes vom plagiat haben sie
selber schon mal was gehört doping lüge
ist sowieso klar salons supreme alex nur
das definiert sozusagen die medizin das
heil des kranken ist höchstes gesetz
staatliches loyalitäts gebot ist nicht
gerade sehr aktuell gebot der tapferkeit
vor dem feind erst recht nicht die
steuerehrlichkeit auf position 14 ist
ziemlich neu als früher kann menschen
interessiert ächtung der todesstrafe
durchaus höchst strittig wahlpflicht
haben wir nicht haben aber andere verbot
körperliche züchtigung von kindern auch
ziemlich neu was ist von ehelichen treue
geburt zu halten
verbot von selbstjustiz auch nicht nur
alte inzest verbot seit neuestem in
zweifel gerät diskriminierungsverbot das
immer wieder neuauflagen gegeben und
trotzdem geht die diskriminierung
fröhlich weiter tötung auf verlangen
wird heiß diskutiert achtung der
menschenwürde alle nicken noch nicht nur
alt kunstfälschung ist meine ein
mittelalterlicher künstler der fälscht
fröhlich drauf los und macht seine kunst
sagen als systematischen fälschung oder
nachahmung von anderen auch irgendetwas
also ganz heterogene angelegenheiten die
man unter den gedanken zusammenfassen
kann das eben eine gültigkeit errichtet
wird die beansprucht eingehalten zu
werden
die also eine art von gesetz oder norm
oder maßstäblichkeit ist
und zu diesen
wollte ich ihnen ein paar regeln darauf
legen die gehen jetzt nicht drauf aber
die gehe ich mit ihnen sowieso durch
damit sie sehen was für ein komplexer
komplizierte angelegenheit es ist
gültigkeit zu errichten was man da alles
bedenken muss sind auch nur einige
regeln der gültigkeit nicht alle sind
welche die mir eingefallen fußball sind
bei näherem nachdenken vielleicht fallen
ihnen noch weitere ein die sind zum teil
sehr interessant also kein gültigkeit
beispiel von denen ja ganz breit
aufgezählten ist eine beschreibung
faktischer welt zustände alle gültigkeit
errichtet eine verbindlichkeit dass das
heißt er hebt einen anspruch auf
befolgung alle gültigkeit hat eine basis
ihm erachten vieler menschen ist also
kommunen in irgendeinem sinne alle
gültigkeit hat eine basis im erachten
vieler menschen und soziale
gemeinschaften also das könnte man die
geltung des basis der betreffenden
gültigkeit nennen es gibt also keine
gültigkeit ohne geltungsbereich das
heißt ohne basis im erachten vieler
menschen alles erachten von gültigkeit
kann aber fälschlich oder fehlerhaft
seien alles erachten von gültigkeit kann
fälschlich oder fehlerhaft seien
fälschlich erachtete gültigkeit ist
ungültig und da waren ja viele beispiele
aufgeführt wo wir sagen würden das ist
beachten wir so dass erachten wir gar
nicht so es war aber mal erachtet wie zb
die tapferkeit vor dem feind oder
staatliche loyalität und dass so etwas
also man sieht wie das sage lebendigkeit
drin ist
es ist also interessant dass alle
gültigkeit einerseits eine solche
geltungsbereichs hat und andererseits
aber dennoch fälschlich oder fehlerhaft
sein kann und wenn es herr fälschlich
ist fälschlich erachtet wird als gültig
dann ist es natürlich ungültig dann
bricht die geld gültigkeit zusammen
etwas für ungültig erachten ist aber
nicht dasselbe wie ungültig sein sondern
ist in sich eine achten konkurrierender
gültigkeit
es gibt gültigkeit des gebots oder der
bestrebung wie zum beispiel wahrheit
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnis
anstrengung geben sowie des verbots oder
der vermeidung negativer gültigkeit
aber es gibt auch gültigkeit des nicht
gebots wie zum beispiel eine erlaubnis
oder auch das nicht verbots etwa die
pressefreiheit die kreativität ist etwas
gültiges etwas wonach wir worauf wir aus
sind die also auch etwas ausrichtet dem
wir nachzukommen suchen
es gibt gültigkeit in theoretischen es
ebenso wie in praktischen
lebensbereichen keine gültigkeit
jedenfalls von den aufgeführten
beispielen ohne beispiele des verstoßes
gegen sie
ja ja das schon das tut ist das tut sie
qua wahrheit
diese beschreibung wenn sie eine wahre
beschreibung ist aber die gültigkeit
selbst ist keine beschreibung von
faktischen welt zu stellen oder kein
faktischer welt zustand das heißt das
gültige liegt nie irgendwie vor das
gültige liegt nie vor als ihm selbst ein
faktum das wollte ich damit ausdrücken
keine gültigkeit ist ohne beispiel des
verstoßes gegen das wie das führt uns
schon in richtung individueller
freiheiten der kopplung von gültigkeit
und individueller freiheit indem
freiheits phänomen selbst dann jeder
entdeckte verstoß gegen gültiges erregt
missbilligung in seiner basis
sie können hier lesen können wir es hier
jede entdeckte verstoß gegen gültiges
erregt missbilligung in seiner basis
also bei denen die etwas als gültig
erachten kein gültigkeit beispiel geht
synchron oder diakon völlig unstrittig
unter allen menschen dh die
geltungsdauer ist keine gültigkeit ist
universal
das ist auch interessant den gegenbeweis
müsste man durch ein beispiel belegen
ich kenne kein einschließlich des
kategorischen imperativs zum beispiel
von kant kein gültigkeit beispiel gilt
völlig unstrittig unter allen menschen
also keine universelle geltung sba sis
für irgendeine gültigkeit auch die
wahrheit nicht
also wenn sie zum beispiel ein ethisches
schrift über wahrheit und lüge im außer
moralischen sinn
das ist also ein prozess protest dagegen
die wahrheit der wahrheit eine
universelle geltung spa sis zuzusprechen
zuzuerkennen
alles erachten von gültigkeit kann
fälschlich oder fehlerhaft sein
fälschlich erachtete gültigkeit ist
ungültig etwas für ungültig erachten ist
aber nicht dasselbe wie all ungültig
sein sondern ist in sicht das erachten
konkurrierender gültigkeit
es gibt gültigkeit des gebots oder der
bestrebung ebenso wie des verbots oder
der vermeidung
entschuldigung ich hab das jetzt
wiederholt ich war bei j genau bei j war
ich schon und dann alle gültigkeit heißt
nach rechtfertigung sie setzt also
rechtfertigung zwar nicht notwendig
voraus kann sich dem nachträglichen
verlangen nach rechtfertigung aber auch
nicht entziehen rechtfertigung von
gültigkeit erfolgt entweder absolut also
mit rekurs auf nicht disponibel
wahrheit' ansprüche also wiederum eine
besondere gültigkeit oder relativ mit
rekurs auf andere gültigkeit
alle wahrheit' ansprüche sind entweder
gültig oder ungültig relativ gefertigte
relativ gerechtfertigt die gültigkeit
begründet keinen anspruch auf
verbindlichkeit jenseits ihrer geltung
sba sis also hat eine nur schwache
verbindlichkeit da sind so regel weiß
nicht ob sie alle sich wirklich halten
lassen aber beim nachdenken habe ich
keine einwände gegen diese regeln
gefunden die wir also erst einmal als
einrad sehr kompliziertes regelwerk in
bezug auf das phänomen gültigkeit zu dem
sich ja dann wiederum die freiheit
verstehen lässt akzeptieren müssen
wir nehmen also zur kenntnis gültig
keiten können somit zugleich gelten
nämlich zufolge ihrer geltung sba sich
sein und ungültig aufgrund fälschlichen
erachtens sie widerspricht nicht dem
gedanken der gültigkeit zugleich in
geltung und ungültig zu sein oder von
vergleichsweise schwacher
verbindlichkeit zu sein wenn sie nämlich
nur relativ gerechtfertigt ist ein
rekurs auf andere gültigkeit so macht
man das hier
solange sie aber gültigkeit und damit
tatsächlich hin geltung sind wäre es
unmöglich dies zu entdecken das sie
ungültig sind wenn nicht mit aller
gültigkeit die ermächtigung zum verstoß
also händler misst sh matthias aus
individueller freiheit einherging
also das ist eben ein hoher wert dieser
antagonistischen form der
kollektivierung das wie diese paarung
von innen geltung seine gültigkeit haben
und tatsächlich ungültig sein
also das gegenteil oder nur schwach
verbindlich sein dass wir dieses nie
aufdecken könnten in dem was gültig ist
wenn wir nicht die freiheit als ein
legal besessen die individuelle nämlich
zur abweichung von hier und damit die
nötigung gültigkeitsprüfung reflexionen
etc
rechtfertigungen durchzuführen und nur
deswegen hat sich etwas getan
in der geschichte des gültigen das vor
hunderten von jahren ganz anders
ausgesehen hat als heute was wir für
gültig erachten weil eben das legat der
freiheit damit immer gekoppelt waren und
nur wenn die leute eben sich dazu
aufraffen und das tun sie mit vollem
risiko weil wie gesagt es gibt keine
erlaubnis die normen zu brechen
die gültigen keine erlaubnis nur eben
eine ermächtigung
das ist was anderes
dann wären wir nie dahinter gekommen
dass manches von dem was wir als gültig
errichtet hatten eben ganz und gar nicht
gültig ist sondern vielmehr ungültig an
dieser stelle also dann für heute genug
und das nächste mal dann bei clean
ich hätte